for the first time we're hearing from
someone who says he witnessed part of
the deadly confrontation between a
Connecticut man and a worker at a
Caribbean resort Scott Hapgood faces a
manslaughter charge for the death of
Kenny Mitchell Mitchell died after a
violent struggle with Hapgood and in
Anguilla now a bellman who says he was
the first to arrive on the scene is
describing what he saw
Errol Barnett spoke to the hotel
employee Errol what exactly did he tell
you
well sheesh Wayne Clark says he arrived
at Scott hapgoods room moments after the
confrontation between him and Kenny
Mitchell began and you can see that
luxury resort where this all took place
over my right shoulder what's important
is that Clark story is at odds with
hapgoods version of events and it's
raising new questions about what really
took place at this hotel back in April I
cannot say what happened initially right
I only came dead for the aftermath
jesh Wayne Clark is a bellman itand
Willa's my Ohana resort and says he was
the first person to find Scott Hapgood
were straining another hotel employee
Kenny Mitchell on the floor of hapgoods
hotel bathroom April 13th
I saw a Kenny on his back and mr.
Hapgood / Kenny Clark says he saw
hapgoods forearm on Mitchell's neck and
was told Mitchell came after Hapgood
with a knife asking for money and well I
was keep telling him okay yes I
understand what you are saying but you
still need to act give him proper
breathing space at one point Clark says
Mitchell tried responding he said can I
speak then in that same position mr.
Hapgood came looked down at him and say
you don't have a thing to say Clark says
he and his security manager tried to
intervene but Hapgood refused to budge
for roughly 30 minutes he stated that he
would not move he would not get up he
will not do anything until police is
present Clark also says hapgoods wife
came in the room after he did and
recorded part of the encounter on her
phone how do you know it was video and
not pictures or no because I saw when
she pressed the record button an autopsy
shows Mitchell died from positional
asphyxia a toxicology report also shows
he had
drugs and alcohol in his system Hopkins
family says he was bitten and stabbed
but Clark says the knife Mitchell was
allegedly carrying was clean when I
checked the knife there was no blood on
the knife
outside the Anguilla courthouse
following Thursday's hearing CBS News
spoke with Mitchell's brother Marshall
what would justice look like for as long
as it takes until just this is you take
a life you understand Hapgood who was
vacationing in Anguilla with his family
back in April says he is eager for a
trial where his innocence will be proven
and someday I will be able to tell the
real story in a legal setting the sooner
that day comes the better thank you now
a representative for the hapgoods say
they deny most of Clark's account except
for the delay in releasing Mitchell mr.
Hapgood has said through his
representatives that he was afraid that
the hotel staff were part of some type
of plan to attack him and he didn't
trust them Anthony the next hearing in
this trial is set for September 9 Errol
Barnett in gang Willa thanks